well I think these young people have
been brought up in a culture of enormous
wealth enormous power enormous
opportunity the least well off of them
is considerably better than the best of
their ancestors I think they recognize
that they see the signs of success as a
will define success and opulence on
every hand they're surrounded by
sensation they are surrounded by
violence they are surrounded by politics
none of these are capable of delivering
the goods and I think they recognize
that and I think there is a desire to
find something that will last something
that would do something that will not
disappoint and when you do that in
veritably you attempted to turn back to
the elders to the wisdom of another age
to something that might not seem to have
appealed to you in your earlier phase
but your earlier phase you recognize was
a deceitful and deceptive one you asked
Harvard graduates whether all going and
they're all going to go ninety percent
of the seniors at any given class say
they're going to three cities they're
going to go to Washington to put things
right power they're going to go to New
York and make lots of money the material
world and they're going to Los Angeles
to have fun fantasy and I think they've
come back from all three of those cities
discovering that like ours is no there
there Washington is not going to turn
the world right side up all the money in
New York doesn't spare it the troubles
and tribulations of living in new york
and all the fantasy from lala land
doesn't dull the pain of living in a
life with no meaning and no value and
that's a modest symbol i think people
say okay there must be another way maybe
Jerusalem is the place maybe a
pilgrimage to the holy city is the place
maybe some Ashraf somewhere maybe
sitting under a Bodhi tree who knows but
there
wiser people than we who years ago have
discovered some of these truths maybe we
even heard them in our youth and maybe
the trick is to try to recapture recover
some of that for ourselves now I think
that's partly excitement
well it suggests to me that young people
are smaller than we think that they're
not prepared to buy a pig in the poke
that they are not prepared to put up
with the triumph of the material or the
mendacious that even the most indulgent
Facebook patron under 21 is seeking
something of value something worth
something that will last something that
is permanent and even transforming and I
think that has to do for example the
fascination with with a science fiction
with myth and fantasy it's the harry
potter thing it's looking for something
that is ultimately true and good they
are not willing to buy the rather grim
valueless godless spiritualists universe
which some of their elders are quite
prepared to sell them and I think that
that suggests a great hunger a great
desire great spiritual movement among
the cleverest and most able of our young
people they know better than to be
content with less than less than the
best and that's what they're seeking